c'est votre rendez vous traditionnel du
jeudi vous en avez l'habitude nous
recevons avec nous sur ce plateau notre
journaliste sportif mutuelle et demi
d'euros pour sa chronique sport du lot
dit bonsoir à vous à michael froman je
suis ravi de retrouver après notre
épisode de la semaine dernière jeudi
donne merci bien et je suis ravi
également de vous retrouver nous nous
perdons pas en pas l'arbre quel sera le
thème de votre chronique aujourd'hui est
ce que vous connaissez le tournis bâton
alors j'en ai beaucoup entendu parler en
rédaction je suis sûr que vous allez me
plairait sur ce sujet comme d'habitude
je vais faire mon maximum en tout cas
dans cette chronique la troisième
édition de la soirée à des champions le
twirling bâton était d'organiser au
vélodrome national de saint quentin en
yvelines ce mercredi soir l'occasion
pour nous de rencontrer les dirigeants
des clubs d'île de france et capturé ce
moment à l'aide de nos caméras
mais avant de débriefer cette soirée
petite piqûre de rappel sur le terrain
nous battons ce sport est un dérivé de
la gymnastique comme nous l'expliquent
le vice-président de la ligue ile de
france dominique pouliquen
c'est un petit peu comme de la
gymnastique rythmique mais avec un bâton
comme vous avez pu le voir comment vous
allez voir ce soir c'est un sport
artistique gymnique et qui demande
beaucoup de physique et beaucoup de
dextérité
on l'a vu mais quelle sur les images ça
c'est spectaculaire intense et très
artistique je vous avoue florennes que
je réponde me lancer mais bon on ne sait
jamais ce sont des athlètes de haut
niveau ce gala a réuni les meilleurs
tout à l'heure dite de france au total
ils étaient plus de 120 venus de huit
clubs franciliens le niveau était donc
très relevé en fait on a des finalistes
uniquement des finalistes du championnat
de france nationale 1 b nationale 1
élite dans toutes les catégories
quasiment
que ce soit en solo duo ou équipe on a
également des membres du team france qui
sont là on a des éléments qui sont
sélectionnés pour la coupe d'europe en
france au mois de juillet et surtout on
a quelques à tête qui sont et champion
de france mais sélectionné pour les
championnats du monde au mois d'août qui
sont en suède qui sont là ce soir et qui
nous font l'honneur de nous montrer
leurs prestations aidé à partager avec
nous il y avait donc des champions de
france est peut-être des futurs
médaillés aux championnats du monde en
suède c'est le cas de maylis camus du
club d'andrésy pour arriver à ce niveau
la tourneuse nous explique qu'il faut de
la patience et mettre les bouchées
doubles aux entraînements je m'entraîne
tous les jours sauf les jeudi
donc ça fait à peu près 10 heures par
semaine sans compter les week-ends et
donc un entraînement ça se déroule sous
forme d'abord l'échauffement et ensuite
le bâton on fait notre enchaînement
qu'on va présenter en compétition
la compétition où passent devant des
jurys en solo en duo en équipe et on y
notait par rapport à ce qu'on fait alors
malgré ces images assez impressionnante
il faut préciser quelque chose mais
quelle ce n'était pas une compétition
isières hier soir au vélodrome de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines exactement
florane cette soirée était plutôt une
promotion pour ce sport avec des
démonstrations en duo ou en solo ou en
équipe l'objectif est évidemment de
propulser le twirling dans une autre
sphère médiatique pour toucher un large
public dans les gradins on recensait
plus de 700 personnes
c'est important parce que ça n'est que
la troisième édition
en fait quelque part c'est le 30 le
tremplin dont on compte se servir pour
sortir du public juste toi ligne mais
pour attirer et des chanteurs comme peut
en avoir ce soir mais surtout du public
extérieur
c'est pour ça qu'on a fait un format
court de deux heures un soir de semaine
on est parisien on a l'habitude de
sortir
l'entrée ne coûte pas cher on espère sur
le long terme attirer des gens à tirer
des médias et faire de plus en plus
connaître le temps d'une bâton - une
nouvelle soirée de gala pourrait être
organisée l'année prochaine au vélodrome
de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
je termine cette chronique par un
chiffre six ans et le nombre de tours
heures l'heure dans le département des
yvelines sont le département avec le
plus de licenciés en france
vous allez prendre votre licence florane
j'allais attendre un peu avant mais
c'est parce que j'ai un peu les poignées
faible mais bon